imaginemos que tenemos al vector
unitario
nuestro vector unitario y bueno este
vector tiene como coordenadas am y vamos
a ponerlo justo así tiene como
componentes un tercio un tercio como
componente horizontal es decir por cada
un tercio que nos movamos de forma
horizontal entonces nos vamos a mover
raíz de 8 sobre 3 de forma vertical raíz
de 8 sobre 3 de forma vertical y bueno
podemos comprobar que en efecto éste sea
un vector unitario calculando su
magnitud la longitud o la magnitud de
este vector unitario u quien sería bueno
pues ésta la podemos calcular tomando la
raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de la
suma de cada una de las componentes
elevadas al cuadrado y bueno recuerda
que esencialmente esto sale de un
teorema de pitágoras así que vamos a
ponerlo con este color me voy a tomar la
primera componente y la voy a llevar al
cuadrado
un tercio un tercio esto elevado al
cuadrado y después a esto le voy a sumar
le voy a sumar la otra componente elevar
al cuadrado
la otra componente elevada al cuadrado
es decir raíz de 8 ok
sobre 3 esto elevado al cuadrado
y bueno si nosotros queremos resolver
esto que tenemos aquí vamos a hacerlo
con mucho cuidado tienes un tercio
elevado al cuadrado esto me va a quedar
la raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de un
tercio elevado al cuadrado lo cual es un
noveno y un noveno ya esto le voy a
sumar le voy a sumar a raíz de 8 sobre 3
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es lo mismo
que 8 novenos 8 novenos y bueno si te
das cuenta esto es exactamente lo mismo
y creo que ya sabes a dónde vamos esto
es lo mismo que la raíz d
9 entre 9 ok lo cual es lo mismo que la
raíz de 1 que es 1 por lo tanto este sí
es un vector unitario porque tiene una
magnitud o una longitud de 1 ya lo
tenemos aquí así que en efecto tenemos
un vector unitario pero ahora imagínate
que llega a alguien y te dice mira me
gusta mucho la dirección de este vector
pero realmente no quiero que tenga una
longitud de una unidad yo quiero un
nuevo vector con la misma dirección
el cual le voy a poner el nombre de ven
quiero un nuevo vector que tenga la
misma dirección pero este vector b lo
que quiero es que tenga una longitud
diferente que tenga la misma dirección y
es más déjeme poner lo que tenga la
misma misma dirección dirección
dirección ok pero yo quiero que este
vector tenga una longitud de
11 tenga una magnitud de 11 unidades
yo quiero que este nuevo vector tenga 11
unidades de magnitud y que tenga la
misma dirección que este vector unitario
y bueno una forma de verlo es que si
nosotros escalamos los componentes del
vector
por 11 entonces vamos a ir en la misma
dirección pero vamos a tener un vector
11 veces más grande y bueno es que si
empezamos con una magnitud de 1 ahora
vamos a tener una magnitud de 11 y por
lo tanto podemos decir que el vector fem
y vamos a ponerlo aquí el vector ven que
nosotros buscamos este vector a va a ser
igual a 11 11 que va a multiplicar a los
componentes de este vector y que era
nuestro vector unitario es decir 11 que
multiplica a un tercio de manera
horizontal y raíz d
sobre 3 de manera vertical y bueno de
aquí que nos quedan
si nosotros multiplicamos por 11 cada
una de estas componentes
entonces nos va a quedar 11 tercios
antes de ponerlo con este color
entonces nos va a quedar 11 11 dividido
entre 3 dividido entre 3 esto es mi
primer componente y después voy a tener
11 por raíz de 8 antes de ponerlo con
este color 11 que multiplica a la raíz
de 8 que multiplica a la raíz de 8 y
todo esto dividido entre 3 de lujo y
bueno este vector tiene la misma
dirección pero además tiene una longitud
de 11 unidades y te voy a encargar si es
que no me crees que pienses en que si
escalamos
héctor un vector por un número en este
caso por el número 11 entonces escalamos
bajo la misma dirección en este factor
así que si antes tu magnitud era 1 ahora
tu magnitud es 11 en esa misma dirección
y bueno sería genial que tu comprobarás
de una manera matemática que la magnitud
aquí sí tula calculas es 11 a
comparación de 1 que era la magnitud de
nuestro vector inicial unitario